yeah totally holding it apart right now
I don't remember what you look like I am
pretending to be busy but I am literally
its reinstalling you you don't edit your
photos you do doing my job oh I'm
ordering something that makes me some
feminine yet strong mmm um ordering
something I memorized years ago to make
a good first impression call back to a
conversation I had online Oh quick
comment till you know I'm on board
standard question about your life ah
generic answer trying to hide my crazy
um thing that worked with other guys um
things that worked with other girls
Oh thing that worked with other guys
thing that some girls actually like hmm
controversial Jets test the waters
negative reaction shutting this down
being nice to the waitstaff not noted
harpercollins talking about the menus
avoid sentence um ongoing conversations
about our actual lives that's what I was
gonna say hey I'm gonna take the
quickest poop I possibly can tell you
that it was a pee oh I'm gonna text all
my friends and let them know this could
be going better lie about how long that
line lies actually checking myself in
the reverse camera hey a joke at my own
expense teasing with humor self
parroting the humor I am touching you
right now to let you know that this is
back on track Oh hugs trying TV Valley
in I'm mortified but I'm playing it off
as adorable Oh realizing I'm touching
your legs and sexual joke different
sexual joke gonna give this energy guy
letting my guard down comfortable
silence actual silence okay a reference
to how much food is still on my plate
how much better still my place because
we are not comfortable eating in front
of each other yeah oh uh
showing my protector quality and
financial stability I'm accepting this
general because it benefits me texting
my friends to let them know that I like
you thinking about our future yeah
ah
Wow